oh ouch that was weird.
I hope I’m not having a heart attack.
haha its funny because I’m not the typical
at risk demographic, right?
oh no.
maybe i am.
Hey everyone Julia here for DNews
let me throw something shocking at you, Heart
attacks are the number one killer of both
men and women in the U.S.
Yet young women UNDER the age of 55 are twice
as likely to die after being hospitalized
for a heart attack as men.
Every year 15,000 women will die from heart
disease.
A new study from the Yale School of Public
Health published in the journal Circulation
suggests the reason might be because younger
women put off getting help.
The researchers interviewed 30 women who had
heart attacks.
They asked them why they delayed getting help.
They mostly said their symptoms didn’t look
like they do in the movies and they didn’t
want to raise a false alarm.
In Hollywood, a man, usually older, gets shooting
pain the left arm, intense pain in the chest
and he collapses.
We’ve all seen that before.
But heart attacks in women look a little less
dramatic.
Women experience more mild discomfort which
can be easily dismissed as something else.
Symptoms can vary pretty widely in women.
Some look suspiciously like anxiety attacks.
Shortness of breath, racing heart, sweating,
feeling of impending doom.
Sometimes women experience nausea or pain
elsewhere besides the chest, like neck, shoulder,
or jaw pain.
So why don’t we see this kind of heart attack
on tv?
Well.
The problem in short, bras.
Before anyone can use a defibrillator on a
woman, the bra has to be taken off because
the metal underwires could conduct electricity
and cause serious burns. and you can’t exactly
show a topless woman on cable tv.
This lack of information leads women to put
off getting treatment, which is a huge problem.
The national institute of health describes
a heart attack as when the flow of oxygen-rich
blood to a section of heart muscle suddenly
becomes blocked and the heart can't get oxygen.
If left untreated, sections of heart start
to die.
Health professionals strongly suggest seeking
help with in an hour after the onset of symptoms.
This critical period is called the golden
hour where chances of surviving are the best.
So ladies, and gents.
Learn the symptoms, know your risk of heart
disease.
If you think you’re having a heart attack,
call 911, right away, chew or crush an aspirin
to prevent more clotting.
Don’t take no for an answer, don’t let
anyone dismiss your symptoms, and demand to
see a doctor immediately.
Switching gears to a much more upbeat topic
for a second, we are so excited that our new
channel Seeker launched this week!
One of the shows on the channel is called
"This Happened Here," and they take look at
the story behind some of the most beautiful
photos on the Internet.
Like this video here exploring disappearing
ice caves of Alaska....
So make sure you check that video out, it’s
the first link in the description, and subscribe
to Seeker so you never miss a video!